et
si le climat ne se réchauffe et pas
vraiment et si les experts nous
mentaient pour nous priver de nos
libertés complot
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous l'aurez compris on va
causer des climato-sceptiques rien à
voir avec les sceptiques ceux qui
promeuvent l'esprit critique comme vous
en voyez défiler sur cette chaîne rien à
voir non plus avec les fosses septiques
à par l'odeur peut-être non les climato
sceptiques sont ceux qui croient à la
théorie du complot suivante le
réchauffement climatique n'existe pas
vraiment ou alors pas comme on veut nous
le faire croire cette théorie a des
adeptes partout y compris en france elle
aurait émergé au début des années 90 ce
qui coïncide justement avec d'une part
la sortie du tout premier rapport du
giec le groupe d'experts du climat et
d'autre part la tenue d'un grand sommet
sur le climat le sommet de la terre à
rio dé janeiro donc dès qu'on a pris
conscience que ça chauffait pour nos
fesses il ya eu des gens pour clamer
mais non c'est faux et depuis cette
théorie du complot trace sa route en 4 4
avec quelques personnalités médiatiques
de dentelle que en france deux très
grands géologue vincent courtillot et
claude allègre qui était aussi un homme
politique et aux états unis comme ça par
hasard donald trump je crois que je vais
pouvoir le placer dans toutes les vidéos
sur les complotistes et c'est fascinant
vous commencez à avoir l'habitude il ya
différents degrés de climato-scepticisme
degré comme la température vous l'avez
ya ceux qui disent c'est complètement
faux le climat n'est pas en train de se
réchauffer très vite et certainement pas
à cause de nous ah ça non c'est pas du
tout parce qu on crame des énergies
fossiles comme du charbon ou du pétrole
et qu'en conséquence on vous jette des
gaz à effet de serre qui vont faire
grimper le mercure non non non pas du
tout qu'un ami ça c'est ce que les
réchauffistes essaye de vous faire
croire il appelle tous ceux qui ne
croient pas en leurs théories des
réchauffistes c'est cocasse et donc
c'est climato-sceptiques là affirme que
ce qu'on observe est juste une variation
normale des températures bah oui
regardez au moyen-âge aussi il a fait
chou en diable à un moment on m'a appelé
ça l'embellie de l'an mil c'est beau ça
donne presque envie d'en faire une
chanson
c'était temps
non vraiment c'est pas de notre faute
ainsi fait chaud c'est lié au soleil qui
tape plus fort et aussi à l'inclinaison
de la terre et tout et tout sépare cycle
1 de toute façon donc ça s'en va et ça
revient c'est fait de tous petits riens
bref il n'ya pas de quoi fouetter un
chat alors ne vous était jamais les
sharks à l'idée le seul truc qu'on peut
souhaiter c'est la crème pour mettre sur
les fraises d'ailleurs c'est la saison 1
profitez-en il yad'autres
climato-sceptiques qui reconnaissent que
le climat se réchauffe bel et bien de
façon anormale et accepte que c'est à
cause de nous les humains mais il refuse
de croire que ce réchauffement est une
mauvaise chose les réchauffistes vous
manipule en vous disant qu'il ya de plus
en plus de sécheresse et de canicule en
été et plus d'incendiés d'ouragan plus
de pénurie alimentaire des réfugiés
climatiques à gogo à cause de la montée
des eaux sans parler de la biodiversité
qui s'érode à vue d'oeil mais non pas du
tout rétorque que les climatosceptiques
c'est un complot au contraire quand les
réchauffistes voient un danger nous on
voit les opportunités le co2 pour l'arc
dans l'atmosphère aide les plantes à
pousser c'est bon pour l'agriculture et
les forêts ça et en plus avec la fonte
des glaces ça nous ouvre une nouvelle
route pour les bateaux au nord ça c'est
super bon pour le commerce vous voyez un
problème vous moi j'aime pas rien et
puis bon on va bien s'adapter à la
hausse des températures dans un
cabaret où il ya du vrai dans tout ça en
mai en majorité les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sont quand même
un petit peu catastrophique pour les
climato sceptiques les avengers du
climat ce qui pour 10 ce grand complot
pour nous priver de liberté de polluer à
notre guise c'est bien évidemment les
gouvernements et aussi le giec ce fameux
groupe d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat est ce qu'on peut
vraiment leur faire confiance est-ce que
c'est pas une flopée de farceurs qui
nous prennent pour des faisans alors là
c'est culotté de sortir un truc pareil
le geiq c'est pas juste trois rigolos au
pmu du coin c'est des spécialistes du
climat du monde entier c'est un organe
fondée par l'organisation des nations
unies et qui regroupe 195 et a en fait
le boulot de tous ces climatologues
c'est de compiler les études qui sont
faites sur le changement climatique et
de résumer tout ça pour qu'on y voit
plus clair de la façon la plus objective
possible la question que je me pose
c'est pourquoi cette théorie du complot
peut-être que ces gens ont peur de
devoir changer leurs habitudes ou d'être
privés de leur liberté peut-être aussi
qu'ils ont honte d'avouer que quelque
part c'est un peu de leur faute en ce
dérèglement climatique ah oui c'est les
comportements de leurs générations qui
nous ont mis dedans on peut aussi se
demander sur est pas un petit lobby
industries pétrolières et du charbon
derrière tout ça ils sont un peu
l'ennemi numéro un du climat même si on
prend des mesures pour réduire notre
impact sur la planète forcément ça va
pas être bon pour leurs affaires et
effectivement en 2019 une organisation
indépendante a estimé que les pétroliers
dépenser 200 millions de dollars chaque
année en lobbying pour influencer les
décisions concernant climat bref tout ça
c'est bien mignon mais en vrai ça me
fait pas rire du tout aujourd'hui après
toutes les preuves qu'on a et toutes les
alertes des climatologues depuis plus de
30 ans maintenant une sec le climat se
réchauffe dangereusement vite que c'est
notre faute et que ça sente pas bon pour
la planète se permettre un tel déni
aujourd'hui c'est juste criminelle
heureusement vous la relève vous êtes
vachement mieux informé sur toutes ces
questions que ma génération à votre
agent par exemple et vous avez l'énergie
et l'enthousiasmé pour changer les
choses alors ne laissons pas nos boomer
de papa ou de tonton plomber nos efforts
avec leurs compos this mme de comptoir
le dernier volet du rapport du giec à
peine sorti du four nous dit qu'on a
encore juste le temps pour changer les
choses alors allons-y gaiement et
laissons les mauvaises langues là où
elle le mérite dans les fosses septiques
jeu passant de vouloir finir par cette
image
[Musique]